In this video, we'll show you how to use the dashboards and analytics features to interpret
the results of your scan and begin taking steps to resolve any issues.
First, you can get a summary of your site's security posture by navigating to the overview
tab.
This contains various charts that give you a quick snapshot of how secure your site is.
If your scan is still running, these are updated in real time as more vulnerabilities are detected.
Next, go to the Issues tab to see a list of all security issues that have been identified
by the scan so far.
These are colour coded based on the estimated severity of the issues.
Issues are grouped by type.
You can expand each issue type to see all of the URLs where this issue is detected.
When faced with a large number of issues, you'll want to prioritise.
Use the buttons at the top of the list to apply filters so that only issues with a high severity
and certain confidence level are displayed.
The confidence level is determined by the inherent accuracy of the techniques used to detect each
type of issue.
Issues with a lower confidence level may require manual confirmation.
At this point, you might want to get more information about an issue.
Select one for URLs where reflected cross-site scripting was detected.
The advisory tab provides information to help you understand what the problem is and what
actions you can take to resolve the issue.
In some cases, you'll find links to the Web Security Academy, where you can find more information
and practise exploiting the issue yourself on a series of deliberately vulnerable websites.
At the bottom of the advisory information, where possible, you'll find issues mapped to vulnerability
classifications.
Additional tabs display the evidence that Burp Scanner has found for the issue.
The type of evidence that is available depends on the issue type.
In this case, you can see tabs containing snippets of relevant HTTP requests and responses.
Open the request and notice the proof of concept payload that Burp Scanner sent to your site
is highlighted.
Open the response and observe that this payload was reflected in the returned HTML content,
potentially enabling an attacker to execute arbitrary JavaScript in another user's browser.
After manually reviewing a reported issue, you may decide that it is in fact a false positive.
Once the scan has finished running, select any issue, then click mark as false positive.
For now, just accept the default setting.
You'll often want to report the results of your scan to other stakeholders who don't
have access to Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
For example, you need to pass details of any findings to your development team so that they
can work on a fix.
Go back to the scan and open the Reporting and Logs tab.
Download a detailed report including high and medium severity issues with false positives
excluded.
Now you have a detailed scan report to share with the appropriate stakeholders to help secure
your web estate.
You can also download the information on your website and download the website and download
You can also download the information on your website and download the information on your
website.
!
You can also download the information on your website and download the information on your
website.
You can also download the information on your website.